en este vídeo vamos a conocer y aprender
a utilizar las tablas de tallo
tallo y hojas
yo sé que resulta un nombre bastante
extraño en matemática y esto o
estadística poco tiene que ver con la
jardinería sin embargo a este diagrama
estas tablas se las denomina tablas de
tallo y hojas y vamos a ver por qué
supongamos que en esta tabla que tenemos
acá expresada refleja la información
entregada por una estadista que dice que
son los puntos
puntos
anotados
anotados por 12 jugadores de basket por
12 jugadores
por 12 jugadores de un mismo equipo
puntos anotados por 12 jugadores del
mismo equipo de básquet verdad entonces
vamos a ver qué significan estos números
que tenemos en el tallo y estos números
que tenemos en las hojas entonces
nosotros sabemos que tenemos 12
jugadores
12 jugadores vamos a hacerlo acá 12
y los puntos que anotaron cada uno están
expresados en esta tabla es decir que
vamos a tener que tener
12 valores 12 números veamos entonces
qué significa esto
los números que aparecen en el tallo
para ser más concretos nos van a
representar las decenas
las decenas de los valores mientras que
los números que aparecen en las hojas
nos van a presentar las unidades
unidades
entonces fíjense que si nosotros tenemos
que si las decenas son 0 vamos a bajar
acá
si las decenas son cero y tenemos
cuántas unidades tenemos un número
coloca 2 3 4 5 6 7 es decir que hubo
siete jugadores siete jugadores
jugadores que anotaron menos de 10
puntos es decir que anotaron entre 0 y 9
puntos ya que tenemos 0 decenas verdad
entonces si hay siete jugadores vamos a
tener siete ceros en las decenas vamos a
usar este color vamos a tener
cuatro cinco seis siete ceros en siete
valores en las decenas y luego las
unidades van a estar expresadas con
estos números es decir el primer valor
va a tener una unidad cero el segundo va
a tener una unidad cero el tercero una
unidad 2
y así vamos a ir completando la tabla
con un 4k
un 7 en este lado otros 7 en este lado y
un 9 por acá es decir que hay siete
jugadores de este equipo de básquet que
anotaron 0 puntos
222 jugadores 2 puntos anotó un jugador
otro jugador anotó 4 otro jugador anotó
7 y otro jugador anotó 7 y un último
jugador anotó 9
supongamos entonces que lo que queremos
averiguar nosotros es cuántos puntos se
anotaron vamos a escribir cuántos puntos
anotó el equipo
cuántos puntos
puntos
anotó
el equipo
en el equipo
fíjense entonces ahora que si utilizamos
vamos a utilizar el verde para el
segundo renglón nosotros vamos a tener a
los valores que tienen 11 como decena es
decir vamos a tener un 1 acá otro 1 acá
otro uno acá por el tercer valor y otro
uno acá por el cuarto valor y luego
cada uno de estos valores que tenemos
acá 1 1 1 1 3 y otro 8 van a ser las
unidades de esas decenas 1 1 otro 1 1 3
y 18 es decir que nos está diciendo esto
que hay un jugador o en este caso dos
jugadores que anotaron 11 puntos
otro jugador anotó 13 y otro jugador
anotó 18 y por último tenemos
este con el 2
en las decenas es decir y hay un solo
valor es decir que vamos a tener sólo un
2 en decenas y que va a estar acompañado
por un cero
es decir que esto nos está diciendo que
hay un jugador voy a escribir mejor el 0
hay un jugador que anotó 20 puntos y
fíjense nosotros teníamos 12 jugadores
acá tenemos entonces 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 y 12 jugadores
entonces fíjense lo interesante de este
esquema de esta tabla lo que nos permite
ver voy a ir borrando de esto lo que nos
permite ver es la cantidad como como es
la dispersión de estos valores en este
caso cuántos jugadores anotaron entre 0
y 9 puntos cuántos jugadores anotaron
entre 10 y 19 puntos cuántos jugadores
anotaron entre 20 y 21 y 29 puntos y así
sucesivamente con cualquier cosa que
querramos averiguar ahora bien si
queremos averiguar esto tenemos que
sumar
pero vamos a tener que hacer entonces
vamos a bajar acá tenemos 0 +0 que no
nos sirve de nada después tenemos 2
+ 9 tenemos 2 11 11 11 tenemos un 13
tenemos más 18 y esto más 20 ahora si
sumamos todo esto vamos a saber cuántos
puntos anotó el equipo en total esta
suma
me da ver 2 + 4 6 7 13
13 7 20 29 y 11
son 40 48 51
51 y 13 son
64 y 18
son 82 y 82 más 20 son 102 es decir que
en total el equipo anotó 102 puntos y
esto fue sencillo verlo gracias a
nuestro esquema de tallo y hojas
que insisto el tallo no me va a
representar las decenas y las hojas me
van a representar las unidades